los hospitales están siendo empujados
otra vez a un punto de quiebre más de
5.600 pacientes nuevos de kobe 19 fueron
internados la semana pasada unos 1000
están en cuidados intensivos y las camas
de esas unidades se están saturando
rápidamente tendremos el 90% de las
camas reservadas para pacientes graves
de kobe 19 llenas la próxima semana si
no hubiera problemas económicos pienso
que la decisión de volver al
confinamiento se habría tomado hace
algún tiempo hasta el martes francia
tenía más de 756 mil casos confirmados
con alrededor de 13.000 nuevos contagios
en 24 horas aunque es la mitad del
récord alcanzado el sábado no se espera
que el rebrote acabe pronto desde que
las pruebas masivas comenzaron el 12 por
ciento de los resultados han sido
positivos es decir más de una persona de
cada 10 en parís el promedio es del 17%
las expectativas son altas por los
anuncios del presidente de manuel macrón
quien implementaría restricciones más
duras aunque un confinamiento nacional
está fuera de la mesa por ahora su
primer ministro advirtió que nada
debería ser descartado
y una movilización en una movilización
general es absolutamente necesaria hemos
sufrir las consecuencias muy rápido de
la primera hora
pittman de laponia back montpellier y
toulouse
se han unido a la lista de ciudades
francesas bajo alerta máxima en esas
áreas se se ha ordenado el cierre de
bares pero es difícil controlar las
fiestas en casas particulares toques de
queda nocturnos son vistos como el
próximo paso probable estos han sido
efectivos en territorios de ultramar
como la guyana francesa que mantiene la
medida desde marzo